foster care really helped me to see that
there's so many other people in the
world who don't have what everybody else
has
so what we try to do during this season
is
see what are some ways that we can do
something to lift someone up who's going
through a tough time
i'm niko tortorella i'm an actor an
activist and a firm believer that our
differences actually make us stronger
i'm on a journey with ikea to meet real
people and discover the diverse and
spectacular ways they celebrate the
holidays
[Music]
maybe you celebrate on just one day
enjoying time with your family or maybe
you celebrate throughout the entire
month and spend that family time helping
others
like the berry family here in indiana
i'm mike berry and i'm kristen berry
we're both authors and we also are
bloggers and podcasters
all eight of our children were adopted
there are 10 of us total we have three
grandchildren and we also have two
son-in-laws so 15. we are an
all-american family
the berry family consists of a group of
people from all different walks of life
and this farm really is a place to come
together and heal
tell me a little bit about this farm
oh man this farm is it's our oasis
it's perfect for a family like ours
because it's out in the middle of
nowhere it's been a really good
sanctuary for our family
we have six children living at home very
active they have big imaginations love
adventure and we recognized that our
children just needed space we really
wanted to give them a place where they
could just make lasting memories
there's really something very soothing
and healing about
being around animals so for our kids the
connection with the animals that we can
have out here is priceless
we all come from different backgrounds
and different families and so this
season can really be triggering one of
the things that we do is celebrate
advent
it takes the focus off of this one day
that can bring so much anxiety and
anticipation and excitement but it can
sometimes be too much by breaking up
those four weeks before we can really
celebrate the whole season in a more
relaxed way
i'm beyond impressed with this family
every december they find time to create
these care packages for other families
throughout our life as a foster and
adoptive family people have given us
things
we really became aware of how it feels
to have somebody support us during those
tough times and so one aspect that we
wanted to draw into our celebration of
the holidays is giving to others but
giving to others in a way that brings
respect and dignity
when you're pulled from your home and
placed in a home with people you don't
know it can feel like a loss of identity
this care package can bring a sense of
normalcy and a sense of together they're
creating real memories and hopefully
some of those can be really positive
memories the holidays are not just about
our nuclear family it's about giving
outside of ourselves that's what they
want to leave behind with these care
packages
what's everyone's favorite part about
this tradition doing something nice for
other people makes me feel happy
we were all part of the foster care
system so it feels good to give it to
people who are like going through what
we used to go through we're going to
teach him that santa's more than just a
person that it's something that anybody
can be santa lives kind of in all of us
it's just up to us to tap into it that's
beautiful
christmas is something bigger than just
ourselves and our hope is that our
children carry that into their adult
lives that when they look back on their
childhood of course they remember the
gifts and of course they remember the
excitement of christmas morning but that
they also look back and remember that
they were able to give to somebody who
was in need
[Music]
i may never leave berries eight kids
just turned into nine i love you